siete già calde san giuseppe vanore a
fondo la mamma in avanti e dietro di
fianco seconda grande grande grande
grande medium 234 relevé e su capito
salta salta stringi tutto che sembra un
budino allora quando saltate non dovete
fare dovete fare
è a lungo e lungo lungo guardo oltre la
punta delle dita e bordi e bra sguardo
verso l'alto leccese e pesanti con il
papa lo senti i piedi che porta che
meriterà le mani morbide cosa sono quei
ferri da stiro lanciato mila ristoro del
colaci ancora centro cioè non sia di
mais punti e 3 e 4 tallone angosce senti
ginocchio a lunga lunga lunga lunga in
croce è stata allunga per la fiera solo
la parte in alto sinarca solo quella
questa qui è la posizione tienila
memorizza l'aria memorizza la calo ne
andrò assente ginocchio braccia fatica
detta d'amelio